hey leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
folge happy wie als ich freue mich
genauso toll wie ihr dass dieses projekt
endlich mal weiter geht die letzte folge
vor circa einem jahr aufgenommen
gefühlte jahrtausende wahl zwischen der
letzten aufnahme und dieser hier ich
freue mich wieder dass sich happy meals
mit euch zocken kann ich hoffe ihr freut
euch auch und wie haben wir sie vermisst
diese fette alte süße zimperliche
zierliche alte junge dame mit ihrem
schicken mund und passsicher jetzt seht
ihr fleisch flecken genauen ein
schweißflecken und auch die will doch eh
nur uns auf essen kannibale der
besserung rechnen naja jedenfalls geht
dieses projekt hätte julius jetzt hier
auf kontrast arbeiter ich weiß let's
play off kurs blog blabla habe ich
gesagt aber happy jetzt habe ich auf
kontraste angefangen
deswegen möchte ich auch dass die ihm
leute die mich hier deswegen abonniert
haben auch hier weiter die videos
verfolgen können sofort am anfang möchte
ich sagen wenn ihr auch wollte das handy
wie es weitergeht kann ich einfach
gucken
daumen hoch blabla hätte thorel gesteine
und es gibt hier die tolle funktion
brauchs levels habe ich gerade schon
nach konkreter gesucht wurde mir sogar
schon ein level generiert was schon 500
mal gezockt wurde das hat mich echt
gewundert aber wenn man hier zum
beispiel den rhein gibt denn der hatte
gesagt dass man für ihn auch mehrwert
generieren kann wenn man einfach den
titel schreibt dann werden wir jetzt
gleich auch die levels angezeigt die
quasi user für den erstellt haben dh
wenn ihr irgendwelche level hathaway als
getan habt beziehungsweise erstellt habt
dann schreibt einfach kontrakt an den
titel und dann suche ich dann noch mal
und vielleicht spiele ich euer ding ins
ja bald mal also hier für den da schon
ein paar dabei hier das schon 3000 mal
gespielt ist ja gut kommen wir mal
theoretisch auch mal spielen können wir
theoretisch einfach mal so aus spaß ja
gut wartete ich mach das mal eben auch
ich muss das base drücken
[Gelächter]
eine stange marsch los los los nein
schon wieder eine starke wieder eine
stange marsch so warte und jetzt ja
jetzt haben wir ja bla konnte ich nicht
lesen
und ja er hat er hat nein vergesst
festhalten machen wir nochmal ja das war
gut warum spiele ich eigentlich hat das
level was für den da war aber das ist
gerade egal ist nein schon wieder space
vergessen gut direkt in der presse mit
dem ding so das war ein richtig richtig
guter sprung aber ein umso langsamer und
vergessen festzuhalten
das tat auch weh getan wir schon sehen
ich habe das echt wirklich lange nicht
mehr gespielt
so jetzt haben wir uns hier dran ein
aaaa komplett aufgespießt stellt euch
das mal vor ich möchte mir passiert das
täglich wenn ich koche dass sich
aufgespießt werde von irgendwelchen ganz
vielen messern aber na ja so kommen
jetzt schaffen wir das und yeah yeah
festgehalten naja das ist den als level
das war für den er gemacht aber wir
spielen erst mal hier so ein paar level
das prix historique pilgrim ist neu und
wurde schon eine million mal gespielt
das ist auf jeden fall cool but there's
nothing we can do
ach nein er ist gestorben naja ich
dachte ich kann mir das umfahren so hier
ist eine straße gebaut
okay kommt man das im hintergrund sieht
aus wie ein penis trololo 0
ach so übrigens ich werde bei happy wir
jetzt keinen tollen anfang als video
packen weil ich finde ihr solltet euch
überraschen wann was gutes kommt nicht
sofort die 110 am anfang sehen
so wartet etwas haben wir darum
irgendwelche poster blabla da haben wir
etwas mit vortex stehen so ich versuche
das jetzt mal so hohe radioaktive
substanzen hier das mich da jetzt hier
drüber fahren so gefährlich wie das
aussieht ich möchte doch einfach nur gut
geschehen so was machen wir da wo ich an
nichts gutes
wo was soll das was soll das was wird
das ach wir werden eine zeitmaschine
oder so oh mein gott oh mein gott wer
sind wir wo wir sind wohl irgendwo
mittelalter und gleichkomme irgendwo die
nuss war höchstwahrscheinlich also denke
ich ja da sind die nuss ach was sage ich
und das ist ein toter dino brach ich
hasse es tote tiere zu sehen man würde
mit dem vfb in stuck in the shell und
esso oder fliegen sondern diese diese
wie heißt die tretow saures bei euch
wusste diese kompletten namen x naja
also natürlich nicht die kommt natürlich
in natürlich die kompletten namen von
einem dinosaurier müsst ihr wissen oder
sind ja ich habe seine eier kaputt
gemacht und jetzt mag er mich nicht mehr
da ist natürlich jetzt hier nicht guten
wetter com startet das mal neu schaffen
bald aber versprochen der anfang war
relativ einfach nur wir müssen ja
irgendwie an diesen eiern dann vorbei
kommen ich meine wir haben ja selber
vetter aber wir dürfen wir nicht einfach
unsere eier nehmen um seine eier dann
kommen sie zu zerstören
denkt nicht zweideutig meinen das
genauso wie ich das hier gesagt habe so
die zeitmaschine geht an und wir reisen
rund bereits rund reisen runter runter
runter unteren terror und ok so
hier waren wir ja bald schon hier kommt
ihr würde wippe tote tiere
ich bin im magen na ja ach du wirst
erstmal noch aufgefressen heinz tacke
terror vor
ich sag nur fressen und gefressen werden
so ist das leben
so fahren wir hier mal einfach jetzt mit
mir im iran in eiern da vorbei nein nein
auch warum
ich schaffe es der mich die ganze zeit
da zu beißen ich will weg ich will weg
hallo lass mich mal bitte lass mich mal
acht er bringt mich in seine höhle
ach so erwarte kommt ich versuch's doch
einmal wenn wir es nicht schaffen dann
machen wir mal was anderes sollte man
mal bei ihr speed also ich kann auch
schnell aber ich fahre die levels
eigentlich lieber so ab dass quasi war
unklug ich habe einen schuh verloren
hallo die fahrt von deichmann ja zalando
ahs reife oder wie jetzt das weiß nicht
ich hab mir noch nie schuhe bei zalando
gestellt habt ihr euch schon mal was bei
zalando bestellt also wenn ich das hier
jetzt also na ja wofür gibt die
kommentar funktion einfach unten rein
kritzeln ich weiß nicht keine ahnung ich
denke ich nicht auf so was ich kaufen
mehr schuhe im laden und möchte dann
selber anprobieren als die im internet
zu bestellen
naja so das war hoch ja toll schon
wieder was verloren aber vielleicht
haben wir dadurch nun die chance ihr
müsst euch das mal vorstellen mit sind
in warte was hört euch mal den sound an
wo geht nicht mehr
ihr müsst euch das mal vorstellen wenn
ihr mitten in seinem kadaver sei das ist
doch eklig man war ja so du wirst jetzt
ist meine welt
aber vielleicht von jetzt unter diesem
dingens daher unter dem monster
dinosaurier macht ihr es auch keine
monster quatsch dinosaurier als haustier
in meinem schuh der hat mir hausaufgaben
aufgefressen wenn ihr wisst was ich
meine
gut gut okay okay okay wenn wir glück
haben weist deutlich auf und wir können
in seine höhle weist man sich aufweist
und sich auf weil sie nicht aufpasst uns
nicht auf hallo
gut gut ok zweites bein verloren also
komplett ich hoffe mal dass selbst ist
gleich vorbei weil unser typ hat gleich
auf jeden fall keine körperteile mehr
hat man was fakt rap hier lernt hier
jetset geschoss lust kommt wie man
karten einfach durchziehen
ok ok heftig ich muss hier ein anderes
level kann ja nicht sein hier tolle
pratzen so was habe ich denn noch so
irgendwas was ich noch nicht gemacht
habe ist dass wir hier gehen einfach mal
hier in den levels playground was wird
denn so am meisten gespielte sword bei
play.com und so was wird denn am meisten
gespielte von die ganzen levels müssen
wir mal gucken
dpa die gucke ich ja selber manchmal
gerne schwimmen einfach mal hier mit
voller und kind war komplett ttr in
falling failing fh worms gold an die
seite die ganze zeit hoch
das verstehe ich nicht naja ich es toll
dass man hier wieder ein bisschen runter
hier hoffe das ist jetzt ungefähr wieder
in dem kästchen naja hey was soll das
hier
so haben wir jetzt mal hier weil wir ja
genau jetzt ganz okay
was hat die frage what horror game das
vierte play the most amnesia kind kind
ihr lasst mich voll auf mich ein ich
will vor
komm komm komm schon kommen schon kommt
schon lasst mich vor lass mich auch
geschafft nicht nur hahahaha kind dein
arm fällt gleich runter wir müssen uns
auf jeden fall namen für das kind
überlegen
das war ein richtig richtig blöde
entscheidung jedem fahrer zu nehmen was
soll das det du hängst bangkok fest ich
weiß ich mach das extra check der
politik der hässlichkeit
ich mache einfach das ja das war schlau
guckt euch mal die position an die das
kind und der vater annehmen dass er
richtig eklig stalling danke hilfe was
wir jetzt machen
okay was sie warum tom blinzelten das
hochmoor und mein gott volk erwartet wir
müssen das noch mal spielen
mit diesem typen hier so ok nein nein
nein nein ich hab sofort weiter was wir
da hin dass schon das ist der fall ist
ich bin gleich tot in what episode in
amnesia stefano buck
ich habe keine ahnung ich hoffe mal noch
mal aber dass es mehr sein quiz das ist
ein blödes level deshalb extra so was
haben denn hier sonst noch so bmx kann
man ja mal spielen
okay denn die gem
was haben wir hier
jboss ok gruppen ja weiterfahren kann
ich nicht oder sogar doch jetzt so jetzt
eine rampe kugel mit einer mülltonne
also springen kann ich nicht deswegen
ist das ein wenig ungünstig ja weil ich
jetzt a kind kannst du irgendwie meine
arme hilfe my name machen sich
eigenständig ich hab mir grad ein
problem das ist ein bisschen ungewiss
ich nehme anderes fahrzeug ich kann kein
anderes fahrzeug nehmen
wir nehmen die wir nehmen mal boombox
bridges zusätzlichen verzieren mit dem
genau der ist cool
ja der ist cool
ok harry jetzt tut es auch cool du bist
cool
jetzt bin ich ja schon mit auch
gescrollt was soll der mist hier muss
ich mich auf jeden fall mal hier
also das ist wirklich so die beste
möglichkeit damit voran zu kommen
[Musik]
die teile gehen kaputt die tiefe so ich
nehme anderen fahrer wie soll ich nehmen
die kann man gegen die haben wir selten
genommen
[Musik]
euro das ist so wie bei profis das spiel
war das noch mal der mann weit geht dass
dahinter ein als kaputtgeht war dass ich
weiß nicht ich liebe doch ich nicht was
für politische aussagen so wir versuchen
jetzt einfach mal total vorsichtig
drüber zu fahren
[Musik]
ich fahre jetzt einfach mal komplett
vorsichtig ihr seht ich kann das ja wer
braucht schon frauen diese enorm meckern
dass man zu schnell fährt
hallo den braucht jetzt hier nicht noch
mal das letzte mal hier genießen
wir fahren jetzt weiter ohne die frau
warte kommen hier gibt es beansprucht
handel mit deinem vater ist sagt
dankeschön
weiter gehts aber nicht für dich was wir
schaffen das so wie es aussieht oder
auch nicht
natürlich das war geplant was sagt ihr
denn ganze zeit geplante zweite seite
vielleicht komme sehr schöne kulisse
gute idee kommen einen der wirtschaft
noch wir sind zwar schon mal 15 minuten
da bekommen ja auch noch da und nun ist
es aber heuer was für mein gott das ist
doch alles eigentlich geht so
beschleunigt weg zu rot weiß rot weißes
bayern fahren
ich mag ja ich habe mich ist ja noch
kein mal bewegt euch nur arme bewege ich
mich einmal unterboten abend verloren
soll nämlich das zweite mal bewegt höhe
von mind
ich hab so gelacht wenn ich das gleiche
ziel geschafft hätte wenn ich zu kurz
davor liegen geblieben wäre na ja das
war es für die erste folge
das heißt erste für die elfte folge
style blog vor allem skywalk hätte wales
auf einmal hat hast du die oma
aufgegessen
ja ich gut gemacht das nicht normal
ja ich würde mich mal daumen hoch freuen
macht mir level mit dem titel konkav da
und dann sehen wir uns in der nächsten
folge happy pills oder minecraft oder
was auch immer